avec son temple et ses tombeaux le
sanctuaire de la lèche dans le nord de
l'irak est un haut lieu saint pour les
easy dit une minorité religieuse du
peuple kurde
ici on entre sans jamais poser le pied
sur le pas de la porte
plus tôt on embrasse les banques qui
supportent la structure les nerfs hadj à
l'aller chez bny c'est un lieu de
pèlerinage pour les yézidie nous croyons
que c'est la religion la plus ancienne
envoyé par dieu sur la terre qui l'a
créé personne ne connaît leur exacte de
la terre mais quand la leche a été créé
la terre s'est mise à exister
l'air est devenu irrespirable et à ce
jour la legge demeure la source de vie
pour la terre le gardien du temple n'a
d'autre nom que ce titre il vient d'une
des trois seules familles à pouvoir
vivre en permanence sur le site sacré au
total ils sont à peine un peu plus d'une
vingtaine dont ses hommes qui assurent
l'entretien des lieux une tradition
immémoriale maintenant bouleversée par
la présence de plus de 450 familles zidi
venus y trouver refuge
beaucoup des éditions arrivée ils n'ont
nulle part où aller c'est impossible
pour eux de vivre à l'extérieur
alors il reste c'est le cas de la
famille il y as ensemble ils ont fui
l'arrivée du groupe a remis état
islamique dans leur village en août
dernier après avoir enduré l'enfer de la
soif de la faim et de l'isolément sur
les hauteurs du mont sinjar ils se sont
retrouvés ici
dieu nous a donné la force
j'ai dit au revoir à mes parents en leur
disant que je ne les reverrai jamais on
n'arrive pas à croire que nous avons
survécu sur la montagne gulestan n'a
rien oublié de la terreur qu'elle a
ressenti ni de son déchirement quand ses
beaux parents trop vieux et trop fatigué
pour grimper la montagne ont refusé d
accompagner plus loin on ne savait pas
ce qui se passait il y avait des combins
constants on ne savait pas qui était
capturé qui avaient été tués on ne
savait rien du tout de ce qui leur était
arrivé jusqu'à ce que leurs photos se
retrouvent sur facebook
ils étaient tous les deux morts morts de
faim selon la famille
les milliers d'autres y est et 10 ans
ont perdu la vie aux mains du groupe
armé islamique et jusqu'à 7000 d'entre
eux surtout des femmes ont été faits
prisonniers dans les camps les histoires
de ces femmes disparues se répètent les
plus jeunes transportés comme du bétail
d'une ville à l'autre
vendu comme esclave sexuelle certaines
arrivent parfois donner des nouvelles à
leurs familles désespérées de les voir
libérer ici des membres présumés du
groupe armé islamique discutent du
marché des esclaves 10 10 combien
devrait on payer ça dépend si elle a les
yeux bleus
c'est plus cher ce magazine du groupe a
même publié cet automne un article
cherchant à justifier la pratique par la
religion l'elysée dit appris tous sont
considérés comme des païens des
adorateurs du diable de ton élire la
plupart des gens ne comprennent pas et
quand on veut blesser quelqu'un on dit
n'importe quoi on véhicule des rumeurs
nous les yézidie nous croyons qu'un seul
dieu est responsable du bien et du mal
si dieu veut quelque chose bon ou
mauvais ça va se produire des cas c'est
loin d'être la première fois de leur
longue histoire que les easy 10 sont
affligés de l'étiquette d' adorateurs du
diable
l'interprétation erronée de leurs
croyances et pratiques religieuses temps
par le christianisme que l'islam leur a
valu des siècles de persécution et de
massacres
ils seraient aujourd'hui environ 600
milles en irak une communauté repliée
sur elle-même qui ne permet pas la
conversion et les gouvernés par un
système de castes sociales très stricte
interdisant de se marier en dehors de sa
caste mais aussi en dehors de sa
religion
les contrevenants sont bannis quand le
groupe armé état islamique s'est
approché des villages et zi les soldats
kurdes les peshmergas se sont retirés
plutôt que de combattre un repli
stratégique disent les autorités
un abandon 18 zidi ils nous ont trahis
et nous allons continuer de dire peu
importe ce qu'ils font nous allons dire
que les pechmergas nous ont trahis
ce sont des traîtres le gardien du
temple ne put se résoudre à quitter la
terre de ses ancêtres
elle est au coeur de sa foi pourtant ils
commencent à envisager que son peuple ne
peut être pas d'autre choix le veut même
l'attaqué les yézidis sont peu nombreux
dans le monde il appuie la paix ne sont
contre aucune autre religion
aucune autre nation vous devez les
défendre trouver une solution pour eux
les mener loin de cette menace de
légiférer mois
bon
selon la croyance si ce linceul imbibé
d'une huile est réputé millénaire reste
accroché au mur
la prière de celui qui le lance sera
exaucé il faut y arriver les yeux fermés
et on n'a que trois chances d'y parvenir
trois chances pour que le voeu de vivre
en paix et en sécurité se réalise
heureusement peut-être ils sont nombreux
à venir faire le même voeu